a los militares británicos ya están
desplegados en las calles del país su
objetivo cubrir la falta de
transportistas que ha provocado una
crisis de suministros en todo reino
unido- este lunes persiste la escasez de
combustible y otros productos básicos
sobre todo en la capital
acabo de salir pero pase por cinco
garajes y parece que no tienen nada de
diesel no lo sé parece que los
dispensadores de diésel están cerrados
así que no sé qué voy a hacer porque
tengo muchas entregas y solo me queda un
poco de combustible
este domingo boris johnson admitió que
el actual escenario es fruto de un
período de reajuste post break sit
mientras que durante los primeros días
de escasez calificó la crisis de
problema global consecuencia del aumento
de la demanda por el despertar post
pandemia
creo que es por el éxito completamente
estoy muy muy molesto con nuestro
gobierno la situación es desesperante y
creo que es muy grosero que pidan a la
gente que venga a conducir camiones
hasta fin de año es muy grosero terrible
pero cruzamos los dedos para que todo
termine pronto sé
el ejecutivo se niega a volver a las
reglas prevé exit y pidió a los
empresarios incentivos para atraer
empleados nacionales el primer ministro
del reino unido- boris johnson reiteró
que no piensa abrir el país a lo que
llamó inmigración descontrolada la
última concesión ha sido la emisión de
5000 visados para transportistas y otros
5500 para trabajadores de la industria
avícola sin embargo londres asume que
pueden faltar pavos en las mesas de
navidad